[Music]
Runk hey guys I'll be in Colona it's
coming that that those tickets are going
crazy I don't know if it's sold out we
keep opening up more levels to it
Vancouver I'll be there February 10th
second show there's two shows Rochester
New York kitner
Ontario uh shreport Louisiana Houston
Texas and then I got a bunch of new
dates that I just added Fort Wayne
sagona Victoria a Augusta North
Charleston Chattanooga anyway uh that's
what's up and then also you can watch my
special right now cha.com grow or die
and uh I appreciate you so thanks and
here we go with the new episode of
[Music]
congratulations
conat it is uh I also want to say you
know guys look the patreon is on and
popping you get a you get an an extra
episode every uh month and uh and and
and extended episodes go over and sign
up patreon.com christalia it's on and
popping as they would as as Young MC
would say in 1999 or whatever it was on
and popping in his on and popping in
this on and Poppin and this on on and
Poppin that was the song and it was so
bad and I remember liking it so much
because I was young and now I guess you
know what I'm going to listen to it
after this so there you go I just given
you my schedule that's all it is really
just giving you my schedule um this
podcast is really just honestly giving
you my schedule and what happened and
everything about
um uh what happened in my past and then
what I'm going to do so whatever I don't
know it's already boring yes dude but
anyway um there's a storm here in La
there's a storm out here there's a big
storm and um it's actually crazy my mom
texted me let's see look here we go look
at my mom my mom you look like all moms
my mom says something over and over
again and like all moms would say the
reason why they do that is because you
never listen right but I listen okay I'm
43 now uh and uh I listen and the the
the the media is making it out to be
like this storm is crazy I outside and I
guess it is but
also Los Angeles just kind of doesn't
look there are things that are happening
I think in every
Reign probably people slip and fall and
hit their head and die and stuff or or
drown you know or you know a gas line
gets hit by a uh a thing and then the
guy's got to come out I I think that
that happens every rain but also in La
when it happens it's it it's so rare
that it happens I guess that it makes
news and it's like storm alert storm
watch 2024 storm view storm Gander storm
storm stormat
2024 guy got stuck in a sewer storm gaze
2024 and
um storm site and
so uh so they'll do that and then you'll
be like whoa all right hey can go can't
go end of sentence cuz can't go anywhere
right people might be like where no
that's the end of the sentence can't go
so
um I uh I I I we stay inside and then
all of a sudden we look Uber yes dude
Uber Eats Postmates door Dash they're
all canceled yes dude they're all
canceled because of the storm storm
watch storm site storm view 2022 2024
storm
Gander and so
um so we're like all right well well
okay what do we do dude we just I guess
we just sit in the house you know got
two kids got the nanny with us got a
friend over last night and storm gaze
hit and he stayed over because he was
like well I guess I'm David S like I
guess I ain't gonna leave I don't you
know I I don't need to omble a up the
hill if I have to come back so
um so we went to uh so so we were in in
our house fell asleep raining like cats
and dogs all good you know woke up
David's in my house I guess still didn't
know Christ was like wake up David's
here also you have therapy yes got stuff
wrong with me so went to do therapy on
zoom and also also
um the thing about it is I thought the
the Wi-Fi was going to crash didn't
thought the power was going to go out
didn't got a generator anyway it's all
good
but
um so we're doing it we wake up and I
turn on the news they're showing like
pictures of cars sunk into like ditches
a house that fell down and like a guy is
talking to the camera like yeah it was
pretty dangerous and scary and I and
you're like oh okay we got a
call uh uh Bruce Willis and Ben Affleck
cuz it's storm gaze and so I'm
like well what are we going to do for
food no postm yes no Door Des yes
dude so my wife I'm like you know look
why don't we take the look I got some
nice cars why don't we take the Audi
though right why don't we take the it's
a nice look it's a nice car dude but
it's an SUV why don't we let the nice
SUV do its business out in the
rain why don't we why don't we let the
nice SUV do its business out in the rain
all right why don't we let it do its
business out in the rain me behind the
wheel and I'll avoid the PO house I
won't even look at my phone while I'm
driving which I normally do don't tell
my wife but I didn't because it's storm
gaze all right so she says all right
here's the list of stuff you got to get
at the grocery store I don't want to do
it dude I hate getting stuff at the
grocery store dude who hates stuff
getting stuff at the grocery store me
why you all you always get the wrong
thing dang the audience ding ding ding
ding oh sorry we didn't want that kind
of cream cheese oh you got the wrong
kind but what kind did you what kind did
you want oh it was actually right next
to it you looked at it with your [__]
stupid face and then you got the wrong
kind all
good you
got and so bro these are the things my
wife tells me to get
check it so so we decide I decide to go
out and brave brave the storm okay now
I'm like driving to the uh what do you
call it um driving to the uh Supermarket
Market
whatever hey
La
hey it's
fine dude I know that a car got sunk in
the thing and I know that there was
there were mudslides and I know that
maybe like a 5-year-old drowned in the
rain but hey that happens every rain my
heart goes out God bless suck you lost
your car daughter whatever it is but
like also when you ride around you're
just you're just like oh it's not that
bad and I go like this hey but hey La
there's Seattle though hey La there's
Vancouver you're all good okay when went
did the shopping came uh didn't even get
coffee dude cuz I was like I don't want
to went home dude there was part of the
roadblock part of the road that I went
to take home blocked still turned around
I got pissed off because I wanted to
dude they go like this my nny says don't
take this one road it's going to be bad
you know what your boy
[Music]
thinks taking it right cuz I'm taking it
because I got to see what it's like dude
right so I what I got the SUV I want let
it do what it do I want to let it do its
business I want the SUV letting it do
its
business so I'm behind the wheel I'm
like I'm going to go on the road that
she said not to go down because dude I'm
gonna go check it out I want to I like
I'm I'm the kind of guy who likes making
the splashes you know I don't avoid him
I go right into him and I let
it on the window you know like an idiot
do you do that like a jackass I'm 43 and
I'm just
like and then I get a little bit scared
right there's always that one little
hydroplane and then my wife every time
it rains did you know that if you have
to hydroplane you you're supposed to
turn into the the spin always and I'm
like
I I know honey you say it you always say
it in all sorts common knowledge and
then I'm like wait if a hydroplan
happened guess what dude I'm
cooked I'm cooked because I go like this
turn in what ways in what ways in out
out in in turn in is that this way
you're oh that's me cuz you no turn in
but what is turn in cuz you're going
that way the back end is coming out this
way but the front end's going this way
does that mean turn into the front way
or the turn
into where you're supposed to be in the
back or what dude I just whatever it is
I'm hitting an
embankment so um I did the I did the you
know the
SPL you know I'm alone in my car 43y old
man with a [__] huge jacket on cuz I
never get a chance to to wear it and
um get to the middle of
where uh the uh our friend said don't
take down the road completely blocked
off
yes dude completely blocked off so
pissed off got to turn back around go
the way that she told me to come the
friend and so I did that but uh This Is
The Stuff my wife told me to
get half and half cream cheese brussels
sprouts three 5 lbs of Yukon Gold pot
potatoes and vegetables and whatever
vegetable you want with salmon tomorrow
now check this out dude I get there
first of all I went to aroan all right
aroon is a high-end uh grocery store in
La it's so highend that they did a
collab with Balenciaga and you're just
like hey you're basically Sprouts chill
and
uh they say like arowana hats for like
$500 but aan Baga hats so I get there
aroan your are too your aisles are too
narrow take out one of the aisles make
them bigger all right make them all
bigger they're too narrow dude there was
this old lady at the [__] arow on and
every time I want to go down the aisle
she was coming through the other end and
because I'm younger and spry I got to be
like oh okay I'll go back around and I
go back around cuz she wasn't doing it
at all she dude one time she came up to
me behind me and she just goes like this
uh and I look back she goes
uh and she just
[__] I moved a little
bit because she wasn't going to talk and
I'm just younger so I oh
sorry can you text them to turn that
down I mean that's so
loud hey just uh open it up I'll scream
out hey uh Kristen
hey Kristen can you turn that down
whatever's
blaring no no no no no the music
whatever that is
yeah um can you turn it down she said
that was just a baby laughing like like
like Billy has a knob on him
um uh yeah yeah The Equalizer the
equalizer on his leg um so so I'm I'm at
arow one dude and the the the [__]
God damn it dude I don't understand the
the the thing barely fits the car barely
fits but anyway I get the [__] stuff
and I go to one of the guys all they are
not short on workers at all okay they
have so many workers there they're like
um what's that one place where you go
and there's just so many people that
work there what the [__] is
it uh can't remember yes fine it's all
good I need um
so I asked the guy I said hey man
where's your cream cheese because he's
right there dude and [__] it you know
cuz when I go to a grocery store I'm
like I battle I battle on I battle like
do I ask them where it is or do I just
use looking cuz that's such that's so
annoying dude if I worked at a grocery
store and people were just like where's
the milk I'd be
like hey did you go to the
ends it's probably one of the ends
right
um but so uh I'm I'm there I'm there but
then also he's right there so I just and
and you know I I say hey bud where's the
cream cheese and the guy looks at me he
says Ah it's over where the milk
is and I said without even thinking oh
and started
walking
nowhere you know why cuz I don't know
where the milk is but that was the end
of the conversation and the reason why I
knew it was the end of the conversation
is because I already spun out and walked
and started walking away from the dude
okay so I'm not going to go back and be
like oh wait hold on where's the milk
the guy [__] me and that dude is a
gangster and that's how I would be the
person who worked at
the it's always it's always fascinating
how much somebody at a supermarket that
works at a supermarket they know where
[__] everything is bro you could be
like uh strawberry chapstick you're like
oh dude nine at the bottom over on the
right and you're just like oh are you
rain
man you just [__] waffles waffles
peppermint waffles down down down there
to the left peppermint waffles say
things that don't exist they'll know
where they are foot
candy down over up on the top up above
the toilet paper foot
candy
um yeah so I got this cold brew from
arowana and it sucks that's all
good everyone's so nice at arow one
though it's it's it's kind of it's nice
but why do I also why am I also annoyed
dude like what the [__] dude like I was
talking to my therapist today and he was
like well you know I was talking getting
real deep with him today and I was
talking to him and I was like well yeah
you know you know stuff in my past like
I you know I I've I've betrayed you know
I've betrayed partners and this and that
and he was like well you know something
that comes to mind is he was like let me
ask you uh you know and I hate to be so
you know cuz so right off the bat it was
in the beginning of the beginning of the
um session and he said but uh look
you're a lucky guy you know you got your
wife you're really lucky let me ask you
something do you think you deserve
her and I
go and I'm like but it's just
Monday and part of me is like are you
saying I don't deserve her because since
but then I go a little bit further and
think he's asking me the question and
then I'm just
like and I'm
like I have a pretty healthy ego but
then I'm like if you have a pretty
healthy ego it's because you're
insecure everything is the same right if
you scream out [__] gays it's probably
because you got some pent up stuff and
want to get blown in the butthole
right who's just on the level dude so he
says do you think you deserve her and I
go I don't
I I don't I
don't that was my
answer dude I'm 43 I should know this
[__] but I'm just
like I was trying to relate that to the
supermarket
thing wait and I was mad
at I don't even know anymore but it's
just like dude why is it so hard to
know how you feel
bro I was telling this to my therapist
too I was like I don't know dude and I
don't know how I feel and I I I it's so
hard and I do so much therapy and I was
thinking about this I was thinking about
this like the other day I was like dude
it's so hard it gets harder and I don't
want I was like I just don't want what
if I just stopped you ever think of that
what if you just stopped working on your
problems and you just were committed to
being absolutely close-minded and
absolutely set in your ways like one of
those 1940s [__] dads you know we
don't do that we talk about the weather
how are you tell me how you are well I
got something bothering me no no how are
you now say now say in a good way how
are you what good are you and tell me
about the
weather you know what I
mean everything's
great I need to be a 1940s dad dude and
just everything's fun because if you're
that closed off cuz also they live
forever
dude you know they lived so long and I
know that life expectancy is longer now
but it's like
dude not really cuz more [__] kills you
now
too CU monos Santo or whatever the hell
it's
called the hell is it called what is it
Monsanto
Monsanto Monsanto whatever it is dude
you know corn syrup and everything but
anyway
um so
because and I was like What if I just
did that what if I just I looked at
Chris I was like What if I just stopped
therapy and I she was like that's my
nightmare and I was like I know but like
think about this and I just like I could
just live like if a problem happened it
just
goes you know cuz you can just kind of
like not do
problems and I know that sounds pretty
[__] up but like you kind of can as a
guy you can kind of just be like that's
a problem and you just go they'll be
fine and and and and you know I talk
about this on stage now but like you can
you you know of course you can just be
that way and then you have to deal with
you know a really painful death when
you're like 82 right because it becomes
that stuff
becomes like cancer you know it like
becomes like your thoughts of like [__]
it I'm not dealing with the [__] hi
how you doing how's the weather that
becomes straight up you'll just be like
it'll become any disease it doesn't even
matter like you'll be a white guy with
sickle cell at the end it's just like
you can't not
not so I guess you got to work it all
out I don't know man I'm trying what am
I talking about dude I I I don't even
know we should talk about the news and
stuff I guess the Grammys happened and
uh people were P pissed pissed off
because of Taylor Swift dude imagine
being Taylor Swift and just anything you
do is under a microscope like from
everyone like she took the a she won an
award for best whatever it is and then
went to get it from Selene Dion and and
I wouldn't say she snubbed her but she
grabbed the award and was like shocked
and then like hugged someone else and
they were like oh she disrespected the
queen you know and she's got medical
issues and she disrespected
[__] My Heart Will Go On uh right
that's what she
sings and uh later on there's like
pictures of them like hugging and
dancing together and [__] but people are
like wow [__] Taylor
Swift hey dude you're a loser
okay also you don't need you don't god
dude oh my favorite part was there was a
response somebody was like Wow look what
Taylor Swift did what a shitty uh uh
disrespectful thing to do to the queen
and then somebody under that said give
us 10 minutes we'll have an excuse and
it was a she had an icon of uh Taylor
Swift on her thing and then after that
she was like oh this is what happened
it's like man I need people to do that
[__] for me
bro I need I need people to do that [__]
for me in my house when I get in
arguments with my wife just I need
swifties in my house that are for me
like retired swifties they just come
over to my
house and my wife is like I told you to
doing the dishes is your job if you
don't do that how am I going to trust
you going to do other things and there's
actually there's much difference between
doing the dish ishes and then also like
you know saying that you're going to go
do this and then that happens and then
Swifty there just right right
[__] I need a retired Swifty at my
[__] house
dude I don't
know but it's storm watch anyway she was
M everyone was mad at her but she's fine
it's fine everything's fine everything's
always fine dude let's oh let's [__]
look that up this is the thing that we
were going to look it up
uh how about how the the where's the
video of that try my product do we have
it yeah send it over dude there's this
infomercial how about when you realize
you remember an infomercial when you
were young and you
go oh [__] today's going to be a day you
go oh
[__] today's going to be Nostalgia City
might as well [__] start getting some
might as well get Rainbow Bright and
some Dipping Dots and a Razor
scooter I I remembered this the other
day
dude the end of this the last second of
this is so ill dude I'm gonna play the
whole
thing it's two minutes got it I'm GNA
play the whole I'm not gonna play the
whole
thing this is pretty amazing I'm going
to start playing May play the whole
thing dude this is just
why can I watch [__] like
this over and over again dude here we go
do you need to know how to operate a
computer yeah I
might I you might know
this okay but this guy is do you need to
know how to operate a computer hi I'm
John Sherer CEO and founder of video
Professor dude video Professor like it's
a [__] someone in Arkham Asylum
hello I'm the video Professor I will
show you how you're going to die in a
VHS and then do that it seems like
everywhere I go these days somebody is
recognizing me as the video Professor ah
where's recognizing dude hey are you are
you the video
Professor imagine getting mistaken for
the video Professor are you video
Professor oh are you [__] no that's
because we've been teaching people how
to operate computers for over 14 years
now bro when did this come out over 14
years
no no no that was yeah way lower you
just pay a small shipping in I'm going
to the end the reason I'm going to do
this is because I know that once you try
my product you'll come back to us for
all your computer learning needs and if
this doesn't teach you how to run a
computer I'll even refund your shipping
and handling dude the end of this here
we go we're going to the end this is so
gangster the end of
this so what have you got to lose try my
product
dude try a product dude we would say
that all the time refund your shipping
and handling so what have you got to
lose try my product call video Professor
now for your free L from Windows word
quick and many more call in the next 10
minutes and this free gift will be yours
the anytime organizer is the calendar
diary dress book and journal on your PC
so you'll never miss an appointment
again remember you must call now to get
your free CD and extra free gift so
don't delay call Now call 80049 2659 how
many different people tell need to say
call now there were three people so what
have you got to lose try my product why
does he say it like that so what do you
need to lose drama product dude
wow John sheerer dude [__] absolutely
hung himself you know what I mean for
sure hung himself 12 years
ago pleasee try my product
the video Professor such a
mouthful call it something cool you
know
um
amazing and then [__] Killer Mike got
arrested now he didn't get arrested but
he got a little bit arrested right he
went and W eight Grammys and they put
handcuffs on him for a little bit it's
like ah just playing man they were just
trying to remind they're just trying
remind who who boss you know okay no no
I know but we're just playing but we are
the cops though you know and there is
still racism so I'm not saying they're
racist but I'm just saying like that
that's a you know a joke you I could
make right now if I wanted to that I
did check out creamy eirl on YouTube and
Tik Tok uh go to my page if you want to
purchase a 10-word ad or shout out
holler. christalia um took a little bit
of a break I needed to get some air in
here but
um
oh man I saw uh you know what I did last
night I can't not I can't not so I did
but I watched beekeeper with um first of
all beekeeper is a movie with Jason stum
it sounds like it it's it's an indie
film with Francis mcdorman you know you
say oh yeah we're going to watch be beer
the last thing it sounds is a is like a
uh an action-packed which it
is um movie where there's martial arts
in it dude I love Jason STM and I guess
I'm out of touch
because I just seem to me it seemed
like it was going to
be I I watched this movie I turned it on
last night David was over this was when
he was over and it was raining he was
like let's beekeeper man and I was like
all right I wasn't really in the mood
for it but let's do
it I I I expect it to be I know a lot of
these guys are making look this is a
regular Jason STM movie I understand I
know a lot of these guys are going to be
doing the John Wick thing now you know
you got brick layer you got uh
Relentless you got uh the other one with
um the other guy just a lot of these
guys who are getting older are doing
their thing Jason STM still kind of at
the top of his game and he's what 50 I
don't know but um this is just like a
John Wick movie where he plays a
beekeeper this is so the way they tried
to shoehorn beekeeper into this regular
action movie that hadn't didn't need to
have anything to do with beekeeping was
Unreal dude it was Unreal so first of
all the movie opens up he's a beekeeper
all right doing his beekeeping and [__]
just keeping bees all around and then
the woman that he rents The Shed from
that lives down the way uh gets a link
to a thing that says oh you're your
computer's compromis so she calls and
basically gets swindled out of $2
million and then she kills herself okay
then she uh you know shoots herself in
the head and dies all right and then uh
Jason stum is like my be [__] it I go
inside and thank her for something or
whatever give her some honey goes over
to give her some honey or whatever I
don't even remember what it is finds her
dead body and he's like oh no and then
the FBI is already there and say freeze
what are you doing here you find out
it's one person that's there the woman
the FBI who is the woman who is the
daughter of the
lady that just killed herself okay so
already already oh and she doesn't live
there by the way they live like
somewhere you know it look I don't know
where but like it looks like Upstate New
York wherever wherever they live they
they
um they
find she finds him there and so already
she doesn't live there the
daughter so already first scene I'm like
why is she there it's never explained
she's just showing up and oh my M my
mom's dad she goes and he's like I'm I'm
here for you I'm not I'm not I'm you
know I'm a good guy I rented the shed
from her I'm a beekeeper I keep keeping
bees everywhere and I don't know if I
[__] I need to go check out my bees
right so
then they're like this this beekeeper
Jason STM he's like he finds
out that she got swindled out of money
and then committed you know pow in her
head and so he goes and burns the call
center
down dude he goes there in this he looks
dope okay he's got a regular jacket and
cool pants but he has a baseball hat on
and it looks it's so weird when he wears
this baseball hat that it's like so out
of place like it's just regular Navy
baseball hat there's nothing on it it
looks like NPC [__] and it's on a little
bit wrong and I can't explain why it's
on a little bit wrong but it just is not
sitting right on his head and the fact
that nobody was like let's just take the
hat off and wore it well over halfway
through the movie and Jason STM is Jason
St because you want to see his shiny
bald head kicking ass he had his hat on
it looked like he had cake under his hat
the whole time and and he walks up to
this uh call center and these two uh um
henchmen come out and they're like
you're not getting in there no matter
what and he's like yes I am and he was
like what are you here for he's like he
had two gasoline T canisters and he says
I'm gonna burn the [__] place
down and you're not going to stop me and
then proceeds to go do that of course
this is a beekeeper
right so we find out that he is a
beekeeper but the real beekeeping is
there is an underground faction that
protects the
world when laws aren't good enough and
they call themselves The
Hive and they're all beekeepers from
around the world get thrust into
situations to to save people okay so we
find out that he's a defective
beekeeper in the hive and The Beekeeper
Society I mean dude finds out that he's
still TR doing stuff in their name and
now they go to try and kill him so
now the evil entity that is
the um cuz there are all these henchmen
in the uh what do you call it in the
call center like they're swindling
people from all over the
world now they're going after Jason to
try and kill him and then the beekeepers
are going after Jason STM and trying to
kill him so everyone's trying to kill
Jason STM and Jason STM doesn't get hit
once until the end of the movie which is
fine I don't care action movies are
action movies but the way they they kept
on like they had Jeremy Irons in this
[__] thing for some reason and he was
just
like he was the guy that came in the in
the movie that would be like where the
movie would happen and then somebody
would need to explain something and then
Jeremy Irons would have a scene with
Josh Hutson and be like like well the
thing about the beekeepers is that
that's the thing about beekeepers is
that they don't stop they don't stop
until a job is done and he won't stop
until the job is done and say you he
goes up against a Delta Force member
that Delta Force member dies because the
beekeeper is the most lethal and we just
like all right so he just can kick
anyone's ass he's [__] awesome and he
does what he needs to do what he's
trying to do is take out a take out the
queen just like a real bee a real be
it's like and dude the way they're
shoehorn hey guys leave the bees out
dude just make an action
movie just make a movie where the guy's
kicking ass and it's just like and it's
called beekeeper dude and so so I'm
watching this movie and I'm like oh this
is I guess this is going to be the the
the thing that doesn't work for Jas STM
I'm like this is just going to be the
movie where it's like not over it'll
always have a [__] great career but
like this is going to be the thing I get
the next day I wake up dude beekeeper
continues to break Jason stm's box
office record and I'm
like oh I I'm I don't I don't know
anymore
who's you know what always the answer is
when you when you think who's watching
that [__] Asians that's always the
answer it's always the answer and that's
fine it's not a racist thing Asians kind
of just like action they don't give a
[__] they Asians will just watch like a
a a a a movie where a guy there you know
Supernatural ability isn't a thing in
the world but some guy regular guy will
run uh and catch up with a plane and
then jump onto the wing as the plan's
above in the air you know and and Asians
will just watch it like oh [__] and
Americans would be like they can't
[__] why did why didn't they set up
that the world is Supernatural they have
superpowers Asians don't give a [__]
about that setting up world
right but anyway dude it's a huge hit
congrats to Jason STM I love that
[__] I thought was going to tank
but I guess it's not I don't know
anything anymore I thought Barbie was
going to [__]
bomb I know nothing about this [__]
anymore my favorite thing was they were
like talking about Jason St movie and
they were describing them they have so
many it's so weird first of all there's
so many parts in beekeeper they kept
introducing new people and they like hey
it's my it's my you're out of your
jurisdiction it's my jurisdiction now
[__] face for no reason you
know and and then they described him as
like yeah he's this big white guy and
Jason St was like 5'9 I think you know s
wrote it in himself but um also wanted
to wear the hat himself you know but
um
so I mean he kicked ass in the movie I
guess it's cool the action scenes were
cool I want I got to get ripped bro just
for [__] me I zone out at the gym I
was at the gym you know what I'm working
on [__] Pull-Ups I put the 45lb
weight plate on my thing I did the thing
I I got five six of them and I know
people are hating like I put on my story
and people are like dude you're not all
the way up it's the angle I did get all
the way up my Chin's Over the Bar
obviously it's the [__] angle but
anyway
um I'm so sore now dude my
biceps you know how hard it is to hang
on one with one arm have you tried to do
that have you ever tried to do that
guess what you can't you can't you can't
do it
hanging if you can hang from two you can
do that for like a minute if you're in
real tip toop shape dude dude hey let go
with
one you fall you break your tailbone
dude I've been practicing holding them
the [__] like this and just lightly
letting one go like I'll just let one go
a little bit little bit little bit and I
was doing that at the gym the other day
some dude came up to me he goes Hey cuz
I had a towel hanging over the thing so
I was holding the towel a little bit and
then part of the the the bar and some
guy comes up and goes hey what are you
doing
and I'm like here we
go and I say oh yeah it's cuz I I've
never been able to hang from one arm and
then I'm saying it out loud like what am
I this [__] at the gym that's just
doing dumb as [__] exercises you know
you see these dudes at the gym where
they're like they got like a bosu ball
and a and a and a [__] 25lb weight on
their head trying to balance and you're
like this guy's a [__]
[__] but he's probably going to live
to be 150 for some reason you
know and so I'm doing that and some guy
says hey what are you doing and I like
oh I can't I can't I'm just trying to
hang from one AR I can't hang from one
arm you know it's really hard and he's
like oh really probably helps you grip
huh I'm like yeah he's like oh and I'm
like now I feel like a [__] fool dude
just a 43y old comedian trying to hang
from one arm like that's my like I'm a
monkey like that's my goal for the what
next few
months tried to get 20 pull-ups and I
got 19 and then I stopped working out
for like eight
months I'm a self- sabotager dude I
really am I aim for hes I really am a
self- sabotager
man but I was trying to get up dude I'm
I'm I'm I'm trying to [__] get my
my my my biceps were so [__] sore
that I had to carry my kids later on and
I almost dropped them
dude they were cramping so hard and I
was I had Little Billy like this I was
like baby you got to take them baby you
got to tape take them dude I work out
hard
man but I'm a [__] I really am I wanted
to [__] I was at my parents house the
other day yesterday and the rain was
happening and I got there and my mom was
like can you dude it's been so long
since my mom asked me to move something
because I don't because I I I go I would
go to her house grow you know growing up
like no in my 20s I go back to Rous
she's like good I'm glad you're here can
you move there's a couch I needed to be
I I need you know where I needed to be
uh uh I needed to be up upstairs can you
bring the couch upstairs and I'm like me
and who dad's out I don't know can you
drag
it she stopped asking me cuz I was like
yo you always ask me to move [__] like
this sucks you know maybe that sounds
bratty
but here's the deal she wanted to move
stuff just cause that's why okay that's
why all right be one thing if it really
made sense whatever maybe I'm
bad but anyway um she was like hey hey
Chris can you help me and I go it's been
a while and she hasn't asked for a while
I'm like what do you need and she's like
it shouldn't take too long and that's
the code for it's going to take an hour
and then my dad's like I'm trying to you
know dude it's just like I'm at the age
where my parents are just going to my
dad then just says how come I can't get
your special on my TV which is so easy
all right you can all you got to do is
airPlay it that's it that's all you got
to do is airPlay it now if you're over
55 you don't know how to
airplay okay you don't know how to
airplay so I'm like all right well Dad
I'll show you how to airpl I show him
how to airpl he doesn't have the airpl
at all upright so I'm like well Dad you
don't have it set ight
because you got you got this on uh the
Sonos and it should be on the Apple TV
and then this and then that and he's
like oh well okay thanks so I failed
there and uh I was just
so bunched up about everything going
home what's wrong with me I was so
bunched up going home Christen was like
are you okay is everything good I'm like
yeah just and my parents are getting
older and
[__] and I got to like I got thank God
for the [__] my kids thank God for
like the grandchildren you know thank
God for them being able to play with
them and keeping them happy and [__]
like and then I'm like oh I had Calvin
too old and then Billy too old and it's
like they're not going to have kids by
the time I'm still alive and then it's
like do I get to have that happiness
he's spiraling
dude he's spiraling
dude
if you don't spiral you ain't [__]
though man you
know I got to come home and I come home
and I'm [__] now Kristen heard about
this jackbox TV thing on the [__]
Apple TV so I got to play jackbox TV and
[__] let's invite you know David over
and and play jackbox and and I go that's
a [__] I don't like games you know
I'm interesting enough in my own head I
don't need to be like
spin
I I'll just think about the things I
want to think about I don't need to be
like okay oh what did you get I don't
need to be like that you know it's
boring to
me so she wants to play this one game
that's like by
the by the way like it's about ghosts
and then you die if you get the wrong
answer and then you have to cut your
finger off and [__] and Calvin's there
and I'm like we shouldn't be watching
this [__] with Calin here and she's like
he doesn't know and he doesn't know but
also the thing's like well now you have
to cut off one of your fingers and it's
saying that I'm
like you know while Calvin I'm trying to
just play
Transformer and um and then Calvin's
like oh is that you Dad D and I was like
some purple monster or some [__] and I'm
like yeah yeah
yeah and then uh I'm like this is not
good we got to play a different one and
she's like n Calvin likes it and then
later on he's like this later on he's
like kind of like this is it's kind of
scary right and I was like told you
we're going to we [__] him we [__]
him up too
late and
um so anyway we played this other game
which is like a a a more fun game to me
where you got to you got to design you
gotta come up with a jackbox TV you got
to come up with quips and [__] and I
didn't really know what the game was and
I didn't really want to play the game
but you're basically a t-shirt making
company and they ask you slogans so you
just write in Lans on your phone send it
to the jackbox TV and then they mix them
all up and then they have now do a
drawing of of that you'd like and they
they mix the
drawing with they match the drawings
with the with the
sayings and you vote on them and whoever
whatever shirt gets the most
votes is the shirt that wins the
competition okay now let me tell you
something right now dude I don't like
jackbox but this is my [__]
wheelhouse hey you're just going to play
this make a shirt business thing with
me my wife and her friends you're just
gonna you're just gonna play make a
shirt with me
dude I don't want to but I got this all
right and
dude he [__] w
won now I didn't know this but he did
win he
won because they all voted for his shirt
and they knew it was his shirt how' they
know well I bought this shirt you can
buy it afterwards and I'm a sucker dude
after jackbox they sent the link to the
phone and they say you can now purchase
the winning shirt and I did you know why
cuz I created it I made it and it's a
great
shirt I had the
saying and I matched it up with the
right
drawings here it
is for those of you
listening it's a red shirt with four
stick figures on it and it says stop
[__]
dude this is so ill and I maybe I could
add it to merch honestly I
wonder I I don't know jackbox TV made
this shirt but this is a killer shirt
dude
stop it matches up you know because
there's too many people in that family
not really there's four but man that's a
cool shirt I'm going to wear it I'm GNA
wear it on
stage on my show in [__] Vancouver
you know wow I have two
kids man I was on the phone with Brian C
the other day and he's 57 you know and
I'm 43 and he was just
like he was just
like we were talking about the rain this
was yesterday we were talking about the
rain and I was like I was I was like
dude I just ride in the rain like I
don't give a [__] it's all good like I
you know I really navigate through it
really well you know like I was just
telling him we were doing our thing you
know and he was like you know what I was
thinking of rain is uh like when um God
cries it's just something I kind of
thought of you know and I just think
it's I think it's sad you know but it's
kind of like life you know and that's
why he said I look up into the
air sometimes when it's raining and I
just
say I just look up because I know God's
crying and I just say I look up to the
clouds and I just say they're there and
he started laughing so hard because of
how ridiculous he is and then the next
thing he said through his laughter was
I'm 57 dude and I I laughed I laughed so
hard because dude the [__] just
doesn't stop dude life keeps going
that's why we say life rips dude and the
humor will take us to a place and that's
beautiful
man godamn dude they're there they're
there
God
um yeah
stop [__] I wish that's what we could
call the the
the um what do you call it the episode
but we
can't I should start wearing this
shirt I'm going to put it on now no put
on now I'll put it on
now I want see if it fits actually it
just came in the mail that's what
Kristen gave it to
me look at Beef you I'm my My Tattoos
dude that's crazy I got a lot of tattoos
I'm getting more you think that's
it it's not
it oh man this shirt was it made a
burlap here we
go I got to wear
it does it fit they only had large it
fits all
right cool I don't look good in red my
mommy said I look good in red once
though
dude my mom says I look good in red and
Olive she's like you know not many
people could wear that a man the stuff
that [__] mom's make you feel good
about sometimes is just fantastic you
know and then and then they can just
make you feel like [__] too can't they
hear it isn't it crazy mixed signal City
dude when you're a kid hey when you're a
kid you get so many mixed signals and
you don't even know how to deal with a
non mix signal hey God that's not fair
hey what the heck dude how am I supposed
to deal with a mixed signal when I can't
even deal with a signal hey God I'm six
hey god what the
heck this mix signal happened when I was
seven and I'm going to be 50 someday and
it's going to be a tape that plays in my
head subconsciously every single day and
it's going to uproot my life from the
Belly Up oh come on God make my brain
completely
functional before I'm born
right
right cuz it's unfair dude and then you
have kids and you see your kids and
you're like I can't give them mix
signals but then he's like oh can I you
know can I poop on the floor and you're
like well no you want a knee-jerk
reaction but you go well H you know you
don't want to [__] shame him you know
you go well maybe I I don't know but you
do know so you're
lying I don't know let's look for a
better place you're
lying our parents all [__] us up and
guess what it's not their fault wow dude
he's so deep and he didn't mean to be
but it's not their fault it's nobody's
fault right something needs to be
people's fault that's why people get so
[__] angry
dude you
know I don't
know
but I guess that could be it you
know sign up for the patreon patreon.com
christalia we love it if you do you help
the podcast stay uh afloat without the
patreon this podcast wouldn't exist so I
appreciate you and go get that extra
episode uh for this month how many
months have we done this so far it's
been 3
years 3 years almost 3 years so there's
36 episodes that you can go unlock if
you the patreon patreon.com Chris Leia
and go see me on the road I'll be
wearing the stop [__] shirt in
Vancouver uh probably won't be but uh go
check Chris le.com for
[Music]
tickets
[__]